the Joe Rogan experience yeah and how
long would you survive out there with no
soot that's a good question
just holding your breath just wholly
well you can't really hold your breath
because as the as a pressure all goes
down the first thing you have to worry
about is Baro trauma so like in your
lungs and in your sinuses and your it's
all gonna like looking over inflate a
balloon so if you try to hold your
breath that's a wrong thing to do cuz
you go so you have to let the breath out
yeah you can't really do that for very
long though like the way people hold
their breath underwater they actually
have breath in their lungs yeah but
they're not equalizing with the pressure
as they go down you know when they do
those like free diving that's right so
if you're gonna equalize you're gonna
have to let the air out or it's going to
just expand and and it'd be extremely
painful and hurt you so you could do
that but then eventually you get to the
point where the pressure gets so low
that the all the liquid in your tissues
starts turning into gas it's called a
Buell ism and then you'll start getting
this massive swelling like your nickel
for a puff up like that and everything
you'll get grotesque swelling and
wherever that your blood is turning to
gas and OH
although all the liquids and your
tissues are turning into gases it's not
a good thing how long will that take
before that starts happening that will
start happening fairly quickly when you
equalize after you breathe out all that
air you can counteract it by having
squeezed suits like scuba suits with
mechanical counter pressure that squeeze
it and hold it in like a blood pressure
cuff kind of pressure Oh kind of thing
so you could do that doesn't sound
promising no no you know there's there's
ways you can you can live through it but
it is we've had this happen to people in
vacuum chambers accidents like
industrial vacuum chambers and one test
chamber and NASA once had an accident
and we've momentarily has subjected
people too close to space vacuum but
very quickly got him back to pressure
and they were okay mmm so all the
bubbles just you know it yes Phillip
news
[Applause]